what does Jim Jim Keller think about
tiny grad
you guys hung out quite a bit so he's uh
you know he's he was involved he's
involved with John story what's his uh
praise and what's his criticism of what
you're doing with your life
look
my prediction for tense torrent is that
they're gonna pivot to making risk five
chips
CPUs
CPUs yeah
why
because AI accelerators are a software
problem not really a hardware problem Oh
interesting so you don't think
you think the diversity of AI
accelerators in the hardware space is
not going to be a thing that exists long
term I think what's gonna happen is if I
can finish okay
if you're trying to make an AI
accelerator
you better have the capability of
writing a torch level performance stack
on Nvidia gpus if you can't write a
torch stack on Nvidia gpus and I mean
all the way I mean down to the driver
there's no way you're going to be able
to write it on your chip because your
Chip's worse than a Nvidia GPU the first
version of the chip you tape out is
definitely worse when you're saying
writing that stack is really tough yes
and not only that actually the chip that
you tape out almost always because
you're trying to get advantage over
Nvidia you're specializing the hardware
more
it's always harder to write software for
more specialized Hardware like a GPU is
pretty generic and if you can't write an
Nvidia stack there's no way you can
write a stack for your chip so my
Approach with tinygrad is first write a
performant Nvidia stack or we're
targeting AMD
um so you did say a few to Nvidia a
little bit would love with love yeah so
with the Yankees you know I'm a Mets man
oh you're you're a Mets fan a risk a
risk fan and a mess fan